hey everyone i'm happy to announce that
i've been working on a glsl course
so if you've ever wanted to learn
shaders or maybe you've tried but found
it difficult to wrap your head around
them this course is for you totally new
to shaders don't worry about it we'll
explore the basics first and dedicate
the first few sections to just building
a solid fundamental base of
understanding to work from and after
that we'll ramp up the difficulty of the
project slowly covering topics like
shaping functions
vertex deformation
the common lighting models and tricks
along with stuff like toon shading
there's some exciting stuff to cover
with sine distance functions and we'll
dive into the numerous flavors of noise
alongside the more exotic stuff like
fractional brownie in motion voronoi and
more
in short we'll be covering a wide array
of things and then using all of that
knowledge to build entire scenes and
worlds completely in shaders
these are all just shaders nothing more
if you sign up now i'm running an early
bird special
so if you're interested the link is in
the description below and if not well
i'll get back to making my usual videos
right away
cheers